all right so now let's let's get into
the work part of it alright that
apparently has no meaning or no one has
lots of meaning but no significance
no one has significance in a global
sense in a cosmic sense and a in a in a
in a in a existential sense yeah but it
doesn't it won't cause a better toaster
be built and you know that's one of the
problems with science is that it has
practical utility it's obviously on a
problem cuz we couldn't be doing this
show we wouldn't people wouldn't live as
long as they live our modern society is
based on the result science but because
science produces technology to change
our lives people suddenly think that
unless it's related to technology it's
not interesting
whereas I say art doesn't produce
anything practical so people don't
expect their and could say you know what
that Picasso painting hasn't produced
something that makes me live longer
right and but and so because science has
that practical side people forget the
cultural side that they the knowledge
side and that's to me as as important as
anything I what I've I've quoted in a
number of times and but I'll quote it
again here one of my favorite statements
from a guy named Robert Wilson who was
the director of the the first director
of the Fermi National Accelerator
Laboratory which is a particle
accelerator near Chicago which
accelerates particles to look at
fundamental structure matter it was the
largest such machine in the world until
the Large Hadron Collider was built in
in Geneva but when it was being built he
was called by Congress to testify and he
was asked will it aid in the defense of
the nation and he have a beautiful
statement but the the end of it was
basically no it won't help aid in the
defense the nation it'll just help keep
the nation worth defending ah
that actually is really beautiful I
think it is so that's why I quote um so
that's sort of it it's a problem of
funding things in a way because if you
fund something people want results and
what you're saying is basically the
whole playground of science isn't tied
into that and well it's a real problem
now and government funding and in the
public people seem to want to fund
things based in fact I wrote another
piece on the House Science Committee
which basically wanted to require and
did to some extent scientists and their
grant applications to justify why what
they're doing is in the national
interest
and the net and what I think necessarily
anything to do with science well the
point is that it seems to me the natural
and the national interest is in
increasing our knowledge yeah and and
it's not in and so if you if you require
things directly to have a practical
application then you're gonna miss
almost everything you it's already been
well documented that probably fifty
percent of the current gross national
product of this country is based on
fundamental curiosity driven research
that that was done a generation ago
accidents you know discovery of
penicillin they weren't looking for
antibiotics so even the development of
transistor wasn't if people said we
won't need to make better computers back
at the time when they were using wheels
and other things and they would have
missed the use of transistors so all of
the things that have changed our lives
even the World Wide Web which was
developed at Geneva the home of the
Large Hadron Collider to help scientists
communicate in large experiments when
you have ten thousand scientists around
the world it was important for them to
be able exchange was also without
worrying about where the results were
and being able to communicate that's
what developed the world wide web and of
course that's changed the world so you
need to support fundamental curiosity
driven research if you stop doing that
then not only do we suffer as a species
by alert not our learning going not
increasing but all ultimately the
spin-offs that are gonna change our
lives they're not going to occur yeah
so you mentioned Carl Sagan before and
my my scientific awakening was a little
slow I hate to admit it I was always
into sci-fi when I was growing up and
Star Wars and all that stuff but my real
scientific awakening I saw the movie
contact and I had eaten pot brownies
before oh and I thought I was going to
see I think Air Force one but it was
sold out so I just went into contract
had no idea what it was about
didn't really know much about Carl Sagan
but you know the opening panorama
Yammer's yeah in my mind on pop Roundy's
I mean even it exploded ice into bread
every Carl Sagan book and all that kind
of what was that moment for you I
suspect it was a lot younger than it was
it was I was a little younger and a lot
earlier because we got older but
actually you know well I
it's hard I'm not sure there was an
epiphany in that way but there was a but
the first thing I can remember was when
I was in grade six reading a book about
Galileo
and and and and it seemed romantic and
remarkable to me the fact that he was
the first one to look up at them and
moons of Jupiter and it changed
everything and and also the courage he
had or or lack thereof at times to
confront conventional wisdom that seemed
to me to be a romantic adventure that
captured my imagination and that's
probably one of the reasons why I write
books is because it was books about him
and then books by people like Isaac
Asimov well before Carl Sagan but uh and
George gamma and Albert Einstein and
then Richard Richard Fineman books by
people like that got me excited as a
young person about the romantic
adventure to be the to be the first to
understand something new about the world
and and so I return the favor and I'm
old enough now that it's for me very
satisfying although a little depressing
to think how old and when what I mean
scientists now say you know I read the
physics in Star Trek and that's what
turned me in to be with scientists so
but it was those popular books and I and
that's why although it takes time out of
out of my research directly it I'm not
sure which is more useful in the long
run and besides I don't have control I
have to do what I have to do when
writing is one of them but but it's very
satisfying to be able to connect because
the importance of a university or of the
research enterprise is twofold and
that's one of the reasons why my origins
project is twofold the university
research university should be based on
the creation of knowledge but if you
don't disseminate the knowledge it's
impotent so it has to be to to fold and
and so I like to be involved in both for
some reason yeah so the origins project
you're trying to figure out the origins
of humans and the universe and we're
looking at the origins of everything
it's riggs it's a wonderful playground
because we look at everything from the
origins of the universe to the origins
of life to the origins of violence and
and and we're we're having we're having
and the origins of the future we're
having a workshop in in February and the
UH nay I and it's challenges so if you
think about it
forefront questions there's a
relationship always between the future
in the past and forefront questions are
always bate about the origin what's the
origin of disease
the origin of intelligence and so as a
curious person I can go well beyond just
my area of physics which tends to be
more related the origin in the universe
when which was got me into it to all
these other questions on it's like a kid
in a candy shop I get to meet and work
with the most interesting people in the
world and learn a lot about a lot of
things so it's just it's really Self
Indulgence which is what most of my life
is based on but it's bringing a lot of
good to a lot of people's as well me hey
self-indulgence and and individuality is
good yeah well you know that's the other
thing I guess I want to say is that most
people become scientists not because
they want to save the world it's because
they like doing it it's fun and and
there's nothing and and that's fine I I
tell kids that's when they talk ask me
what they should do I say do what you
enjoy because if you don't enjoy you're
not gonna do well anyway yeah but I do
science you know it's great if it has an
impact in one way or another but I do it
because I enjoy it and in that and I and
I am unabashed about that yeah so I'm
very proud that on this show I which I
try to bring on people of all kinds of
beliefs and political persuasions and
all that stuff I get tons of email from
religious people even though they know
that I'm not a believer yeah that's
tough so we don't have to dive too much
into the atheism thing but can you how
about you give me the best cell job in
like three minutes on the Big Bang like
just something that someone that that is
a believer of religion could say well
maybe there's something here maybe
there's some well the point is that it's
it's it's it's sad that I have to do
that because did I leave too much with
that question maybe I should untangle
them no no but I mean one makes it sound
like the Big Bang is on a different
footing than the fact that the earth is
round it's not the Big Bang happened
same with evolution it's not you know
people get hung up in the word theory
well you know if someone just wrote me
and said well you know it's a theory and
I said what gravity is a theory too so
if you don't believe it walk out the
four-hour window it's but the point is a
theory in science means it's been tested
theories are very high-level in science
it means it's satisfied to test to
experiment over and over and over again
and the fact that the universe began
that the universe was once smaller than
it is today and smaller and smaller and
smaller and was once contained in a
microscopic region 13.8 billion years
ago
that expanded dramatically is is is a
fact and it and everything we see we
recognize about the universe is only
understandable in that context there are
lots of independent ways to measure the
age of the universe and we come up with
13.8 billion years we measure the fact
the universe expanding working backwards
it was once smaller than it is and if we
extrapolate back and say what happened
when a smaller we make predictions about
things that we hadn't seen before people
say evolution or the Big Bang are
historical science because no one was
around they often write me no one was
around to know so how do you know and I
say well the point is all science is
historical because all science is based
on explaining some observations are done
but then making predictions of things
that haven't been done and both
evolution and the Big Bang make
predictions about things that weren't
seen before if if the Big Bang happened
we were predicted it was predicted
although a lot of Sciences didn't know
about it until after the fact that there
should be a universal background of
radiation coming at us that was once
3,000 degrees in temperature that's now
three degrees that's been measured with
exquisite prediction yeah our squiz it
precision sorry
and also we predict that 25% of the
universe should be helium and almost 75%
the universe should be hydrogen and one
part in ten billion the universe should
be lithium we go out and measure that
ten orders of magnitude so we make tons
of predictions of things that's what
science is not just a story like
religion it makes predictions and if
those predictions don't agree with
observations they're wrong so so we
throw the up we throw it out like
yesterday's newspaper so the story that
word historical science which a lot of
fundamentalists use to try and discredit
evolution the Big Bang is nonsense
because they're not historical any more
than anything else they make predictions
about observations that are gonna be
made in the future and every observation
we made about the universe is consistent
only with that picture and inconsistent
with any other idea yeah so you would
say the evidence that we have for the
Big Bang is as much evidence as we have
the dinosaurs existed right it's just a
different that we have yeah more
moreover we have evidence that dinosaurs
didn't exist when humans exist no matter
what they show in that silicon's
it's easy to say yeah I've been there I
would they're there the day it opened
how do you feel about that it was a
remarkable experience I was there then
they opened I flew to to Cincinnati and
then into Kentucky on the other side
where was that morning to lead to be the
keynote speaker in a protest that
morning and then because it is it's it's
that willingness the SATA it's it's
child abuse the idea is okay they
believe something and and therefore they
don't want kids to know what really
happened they don't want kids to know
that evolution happened because somehow
it might reduce their faith in God and
so the idea that you want your kids to
not know how the universe works because
for fear that they lose our faith is no
different than the Taliban when they
won't keep say kids anything but but
memorizing the Quran and and and so it's
it's worse than ignorance it's that it's
it's child abuse so I would so I went
there and protested and then I actually
I had credentials I was a commentator
for NPR and I went up to right
afterwards and they recognized me and
they said oh professor Krauss your
credentials didn't arrived you can't go
anymore so I said that's okay I happen
to have a crew from PBS and and BBC that
are following me right now do you mind
if they film me not being allowed in the
museum and then I got a guided tour by
at that time the vice president museum
and it was it was it was shocking it's
amazing they do a bait-and-switch it was
amazing and they start out quite upfront
in the open saying reason and faith they
bright in the front door a reason to
faith why should and they point out that
the two are different and then they and
they and then in the front are you
should believe in reason you should
believe in faith and then and then they
halfway through the museum they make it
seem like a Natural History Museum so
they do this bait and switch and but the
but it's hysterical because they have a
Garden of Eden with Adam and Eve both
politically correct Adam is and graphs
up to here and Eve has hair down to
there but they have dinosaurs you know
in the Garden of Eden of course and the
trying to source wrecks you know is
there it's got sharp teeth why
everything was a vegetarian in the
Garden of Eden you may not have realized
that but but if you go to the museum
we'll discover that and it's so they
could open pineapples so they could eat
that's why the Tyrannosaurus Rex had
sharp teeth Wow you know I knew I was
going to learn something there you go
you here today
I'm glad that that will and are being it
all right we all have a couple minutes
left I'm curious do you find that you
have colleagues that believe in
everything that you just said there or
you know everything that we've talked
about the the ideas of everything you
said but at the same time are there some
people that do take the leap of faith
oh sure then and then believe in things
that aren't on the same time yeah first
by the way we should say as scientists
we should never use the word believe I
know no I mean I mean as it's just I
fall in that trap too believing is you
know is not part of science it's is it
likely or unlikely and that's the
question yeah but of course they're
religious scientists but as I like to
say there are scientists or Republicans
I mean the scientists believe it or not
are human beings and human beings are in
some sense hardwired to believe two
mutually inconsistent things at the same
time I often say that we all have to
believe ten impossible things before
breakfast just to get up in the morning
you have to believe you like your job or
your spouse or whatever yet we all
invent stories to go by and so there are
scientists religious as long as they
don't let that religious faith to
interfere with their work it doesn't
matter and and the good scientists so
that way but but but the making the
claim that their scientists are
religious does not mean that they're
compatible
neither does making the claim that
science derives from religion because it
does I mean but you know in the history
of West at least all of universities
were once religious institutions because
as I like to say in the 17th century the
church was the National Science
Foundation was the only plate if you
wanted to get money yeah then that was
the place to get it if you wanted to
support your idea so it's not too
surprising that science grew out of
religion but as I also like to say and
again to plug to sit in the app and to
say in the new book yeah that you know
children often move away from their
parents okay and so so talking about the
background does not mean that that
science and religion are compatible
because they're not there they're not
compatible in the sense of being
compatible with the specific doctrines
or the world's great religions science
isn't incompatible at the vague notion
that there may be purpose to the
universe there's no evidence of it
whatsoever right and there's no need for
a God as I showed in my last book
there's no need for even supernatural
stuff to create a whole universe but
science can't disprove the notion of
someday
okay but what I can say is you know the
earth didn't stop when someone blew a
trumpet and there wasn't a virgin earth
and all of those things that's
incompatible with what we know about the
universe yeah all right we have two
minutes left what is one thing that
people aren't thinking about that you're
a physicist theoretical physicist you're
thinking of something on a day to day
basis that the average person is not
thinking about give me something that we
shot two things that we should be
thinking about that we're not well I
don't know what we should but something
something fun is that the is the future
of the universes is different than we
might believe it might be in fact we we
may be living at a very special time in
the history of the universe and and when
it turns out that what we've just
discovered about the Higgs boson tells
us that everything we see in the
universe may be unstable that that
matter as we know it could not
immediately so don't go ahead and sell
your stocks or anything yeah but that in
the far future that not only we know the
rest of universal disappear because it's
already expanding away from us faster
than the speed of light at least it's
receding from us faster than the speed
of light so that and and so the longer
we wait the less will we'll be able to
see of the universe but it turns out
that like an icicle on a window or ice
crystal on a window and a summer morning
will eventually melt the Higgs field
that is allowing everything we now see
to exist could eventually melt in a
different kind of way and if it does
then matter as we know it will disappear
so we should enjoy our brief moment in
the Sun yeah so it's not gonna happen
tomorrow no and if we're right we're on
the hairy edge of it it may never happen
and we what we're trying to discover at
the Large Hadron Collider is will it
happen or or might it happen but even if
it was we know it's not going to happen
for a heck of a long time yeah so
there's time to try and make sure we
keep the present world working which
means we have to vote responsibly and
ask yourself what when you hear
something on TV as the former publisher
of the New York Times said and I use my
mantra I like to keep an open mind but
not so open that my brains fall out
all right well that's a perfect ending I
hope you'll come back in March when you
do a proper press tour okay that'll be
fun this and then I can promote yeah
yeah it's true it's good and it
sometimes works occasionally it works
all right well for more on Lawrence's
working there is a ton of it and he's
written a gajillion books I will put the
link down to to the new book right below
check out Kraus faculty dot asu.edu
you